every single entrepreneurial lesson I've
ever learned in my life came from my
acting career so I started my whole
career as an actress I moved to New York
City when I was 20 I dropped out of
college then I ended up booking my dream
role in the Broadway national tour of
The Wedding Singer and realized while
I'm touring the country on a bus doing
the thing that I thought that I was born
to do oh my God this isn't what I
thought it was going to be I don't know
if I want this and before I knew it I
had built this brand that couldn't have
been further from who I really was and
when you're out of alignment with
yourself the universe will sometimes
step in and like smack you back into
alignment and a lot of the times it hurt
and that's what happened to me and
everything was pretty much taken from me
in like a week the show got cancelled
and I was in this horrible place where I
was pretending to be somebody that I
wasn't and I was forced to figure it out
and it took me a while and it took a lot
of businesses to get to where I am today
and I tried a lot of different things
but more importantly I learned how to
build brand and promote myself as Who I
Really Am